what happens to highly contaminated  water when it is placed in scp-914 the  Clockworks Dr Ira selected one pint of  Highly contaminated water for  experimentation it was placed into the  machine on the setting fine and this was  the resulting output a balloon-like  instance resembling a tardigrade it was  entirely translucent and able to float  around the room Dr Ira then noted it  would appear that all the tissue making  this thing up is extremely loose samples  of bacterial in the initial pint of  water in addition to small water  molecule chains holding it together  apologies for the rule bending here I'd  honestly completely forgotten about  microscopic beings in context of this  thing